dancing with resistance is what's on
today's program the a called a saw blade
goes to great lengths to improve the
dancing techniques of its students tons
of it here and the whole place the
setting means that the students do
everything to really immerse themselves
into working their body 20 students from
15 African countries like Ivory Coast
and Tanzania have enrolled this year
courses are taught in French and English
instructions are given twice Oliva de
Vogel comes from chat where there's no
dance training his commitment and
expression more than make up for his
lack of experience all these dance
techniques are new to me I'm used to the
European or disco dance styles but here
I've discovered modern contemporary
dance all the movements are completely
new for me I'm trying to learn
everything I can and I've managed to
find my feet Jermaine Akane a star of
Senegalese dance says she founded the
Dance Academy exactly for students like
a lever du vogel a choreographer from
New York supports her that might be
because the three 3-month sessions are
hard work the training with renowned
choreographers from America and France
is pure and professional sendeth salt
we're the only Center in the whole of
Africa that invites dancers from a
francophone angle phone and lousã
foreign countries we provide
scholarships so that students can
realize their dream of dancing most of
the money for the scholarships comes
from sponsors within and outside Senegal
the competition to get a place at the
school is tough prospective students
have to prove their dance credentials
but being socially engaged can help to
Haleiwa de volga was considered because
of his
with street children he looks after
several abandoned children in the
Chadian capital not the Jimena he's had
to work hard for months to earn their
trust at the dance girl he hopes to get
new ideas which he can incorporate in
his work food donating my love thee I
want to give the children hope that's my
innermost need I'm not doing it to make
money I just want to make the hard life
these Street children have a little
easier alla vita BOGO needs this
training to expand his street children
project but first he has to get used to
the formal language of african dance in
da coldest table many students learn to
interpret their own traditional dances
in a different way